Grazie.
Grazie, vedo che vi fidate, che applaudite in antico.
Allora, questa sera siamo alla seconda delle tre grandi, tre fra le grandi rivolte popolari del Medioevo che mi sono proposto di raccontare.
Ieri eravamo nella Francia rurale e adesso siamo nell'Italia delle città, un mondo, chi di voi c'era ieri, vedrà che è un mondo completamente diverso e anche molto più complesso, perché quella che raccontiamo stasera è la più grande rivolta non contadina ma operaia, non rurale ma urbana, che ci sia stata nel Medioevo e anche la più grande rivolta popolare che ci sia stata in Italia forse per molti secoli.
Siamo dunque a Firenze dove venerdì 18 giugno 1378 il gonfaloniere di giustizia, Salvestro di Messera alla Manno dei Medici, riunisce a Palazzo Vecchio i priori, e cioè la giunta che governa la città di Firenze, e presenta la proposta di rafforzare gli ordinamenti di giustizia contro i magnati.
Che cosa vuol dire tutto questo? Non lasciatevi ingannare dal fatto che questo è un Medici. I Medici non sono ancora i signori di Firenze.
Sono una grossa famiglia di banchieri, una grossa famiglia del popolo grasso, come dicono loro, e cioè non nobili, non molto antichi, ma gente che ha fatto un sacco di soldi e che in città conta molto, però tutti sanno che non sono nobili, non sono gli uberti, ecco no, sono popolo anche loro, popolo di quello che ha fatto fortuna.
Il gonfaloniere di giustizia è il principale funzionario esecutivo della città, è l'uomo che mantiene l'ordine in città, è l'uomo che comanda la polizia, è l'uomo che sovrintende alle prigioni, agli arresti, agli interrogatori, sotto tortura se ce n'è bisogno,
alle esecuzioni, è il principale esponente della giunta appunto che governa la città, otto priori più il gonfaloniere di giustizia.
Giustizia. Questa giunta, devo entrare un po' in dettaglio, ma è inimmaginabile il modo in cui funzionava il comune di Firenze in quel momento.
Questo è un governo di popolo, un governo di popolo vuol dire che tutti possono partecipare, tutti? Beh, intendiamoci.
Il popolo vuol dire la gente che lavora, che è a casa, bottega, quindi il popolo vuol dire gli imprenditori fondamentalmente, se vogliamo usare un termine nostro, però tutti.
E quindi, mentre c'è il popolo grasso, che sono gli industriali della lana, e sono i grandi banchieri, a cosa ancora? I giudici, gli importatori di tessuti, i grandi mercanti, quello è il popolo grasso.
I medici, nel senso di quelli che sono laureati in medicina. E poi però gli imprenditori sono anche il calzolaio, il muratore, il fabbro, l'oste, e anche loro partecipano al governo.
Questo vuol dire un governo di popolo, un governo a cui quindi un sacco di gente partecipa, migliaia di cittadini hanno titolo per occupare degli uffici del governo cittadino.
Il governo cittadino comprende un'infinità di commissioni, sotto commissioni, che vengono create in tutti i momenti, quindi ci sono grosse possibilità effettivamente, per qualunque cittadino che abbia anche soltanto una piccola attività,
qualche volta nella vita di sedere in una commissione che prende delle decisioni. La commissione più importante di tutti sono gli otto priori e il gonfaloniere.
Loro sono quelli che comandano davvero. Sono il governo della città. Loro dicono la signoria.
Prima sorpresa. I priori, sorpresa per noi che siamo ossessionati da questa idea negli ultimi tempi, che i governi devono durare.
Perché se i governi non durano per l'intera legislatura, chissà quale sciagura ci aspetta.
La governabilità. La stabilità del governo. Loro, strana gente, ragionava in modo completamente diverso.
Nessuno deve stare al governo troppo a lungo. Nessuno deve prendere troppo potere.
Perciò i priori restano in carica due mesi. Dopo due mesi se ne fanno degli altri.
Così sono contenti tutti. Tutti hanno la possibilità di accedere al governo una volta nella vita.
È quello che loro chiamano un governo largo.
Seconda sorpresa. Come vengono nominati i priori?
Non vengono nominati. Vengono tirati a sorte.
Fra tutti gli iscritti alle corporazioni.
Le corporazioni, ripetiamolo, non radunano l'intera popolazione.
Radunano gli imprenditori, ma anche i piccoli.
Sono tante. I membri delle corporazioni sono centinaia o migliaia per ogni corporazione.
Per ogni arte, come dicono i fiorentini.
E ci sono gli elenchi degli iscritti.
E periodicamente si fanno dei grandi sacchi, delle borse, dicono loro.
Dove i capi di ogni corporazione si riuniscono e dicono allora
per il sorteggio dei priori in futuro,
chi mettiamo dentro dei nostri?
Chiaro che a quel punto quello che conta è essere quello che decide quali nomi mettere nei sacchi.
Però nei sacchi si mettono centinaia, migliaia di nomi.
Centinaia o migliaia di bigliettini.
Su ognuno c'è il nome di un iscritto alla corporazione.
Poi si chiudono i sacchi.
Ogni due mesi si riaprono e si tirano fuori i nomi.
Così funziona il governo di Firenze.
Un governo di popolo.
E voi capite, se dovessimo trovare un paragone con oggi
potremmo dire che è il governo della Confindustria,
di Confartigianato, di Confesercenti, tutti, non solo dei ricchi.
Chi rimane fuori?
E rimangono fuori i dipendenti.
Rimangono fuori i lavoranti, i garzoni, gli operai,
quelli che lavorano sotto padrone e non hanno niente di loro.
E quelli sono tanti, tantissimi,
non solo perché in ogni bottega c'è un garzone,
ma perché Firenze è una grande città industriale
dove c'è un'attività industriale che dà lavoro
a 15.000 persone, a occhio e croce,
in una città che non ha neanche 100.000 abitanti.
Ecco, un'enorme attività industriale.
Il tessile.
Il tessile, la lana.
L'arte della lana è la corporazione degli industriali,
dei padroni.
E ogni industriale dà lavoro a un'infinità di operai.
Loro non sono iscritti, non sono sindacalizzati,
non sono organizzati,
non possono essere estratti a sorte
per occupare un posto nel governo della città.
Chiariamoci meglio l'industria.
Noi quando pensiamo all'industria pensiamo subito ai capannoni
e alle forze, ecco, non c'è quello o poco,
ma è un'industria lo stesso perché è un'attività su grande scala.
Il lanaiolo è uno che importa lana dall'estero,
la fa venire dalla sud, la fa venire dalla Spagna,
dall'Inghilterra, investendo migliaia di fiorini
e questa lana ogni giorno entrano a Firenze
carovane di muli, di asini,
carichi di sacchi di lana grezza.
E poi l'industriale, il lanaiolo,
è quello che distribuisce questa lana grezza
a domicilio a una marea di operai,
ognuno dei quali fa una delle tante cose che bisogna fare.
In particolare c'è un'attività
che non richiede nessuna specializzazione particolare,
pettinare la lana, cardare la lana.
C'è un enorme lavoro per trasformare la lana grezza
in qualche cosa che si può poi tessere.
E tutto questo lavoro viene fatto a domicilio
da gente a cui il padrone fa consegnare la lana grezza,
poi la ritira lavorata
e poi la porta a domicilio ad altri operai più specializzati,
i tessitori, che a casa hanno il telaio
e producono il tessuto.
Che poi viene rifinito in mille modi da altri operai
e qui davvero anche in capannoni industriali,
perché ci sono attività pressatura dei tessuti
che loro hanno imparato che si possono fare a macchina
e quindi ci sono macchinari, presse.
E come funzionano?
Con l'acqua, con l'acqua dell'Arno, con l'acqua dei canali.
E quindi la città è anche piena di impianti industriali
dove altri operai fanno altre fasi.
Alla fine dieci operai che hanno fatto dieci operazioni diverse
hanno prodotto una pezza di un tessuto pregiato
che poi il padrone esporta in tutta Europa.
L'ho fatta lunga ma sono loro i nostri protagonisti, eh?
Sono tutti questi che hanno mille nomi
che noi non capiamo neanche più.
Ci sono i pettinatori, gli scardassieri, i cimatori, i tagliatori
e poi i tintori naturalmente, mille mestieri.
Ma tutta questa gente ha una cosa in comune,
sono sottoposti dell'arte della lana,
non partecipano al governo della città.
Cosa tiene insieme il popolo che governa?
Perché voi capite bene che fra il grande banchiere internazionale
e il ciabattino all'angolo non c'è più tanto in comune.
Ma in realtà c'è ancora qualcosa che li tiene insieme
perché da sempre loro hanno un nemico
e sono i nobili, i magnati come dicono loro, i grandi.
Chi sono i grandi?
Sono le famiglie che in passato governavano la città.
Sono quelli che vivono nei palazzi con le torri.
Avete presente San Gimignano?
Ecco, le nostre città medievali erano tutte come San Gimignano.
In una città come Firenze c'erano più di cento torri
e ognuna di queste torri apparteneva a una famiglia,
a una consorteria, a nobili.
I nobili sono quelli che non è che non lavorano,
perché le mani in pasta negli affari ce li hanno anche loro,
nella banca, ma non vanno a bottega.
E sono ricchi da tanto tempo, hanno comprato terra,
hanno comprato signorie intere, castelli in campagna,
hanno folle di contadini che lavorano per loro.
E i nobili, anche se sono venuti su in una città italiana
facendo i soldi nei modi che si fanno in Italia,
però loro sanno che all'estero un nobile è innanzitutto un cavaliere.
È uno che va a cavallo, che possiede le armi,
che sa combattere, che fa i tornei
e anche i nobili italiani vogliono fare queste cose.
Quindi a Firenze i nobili sono le grandi famiglie antiche
abituate a comandare da un pezzo e armati,
sono quelli che hanno i cavalieri in famiglia.
E per tanto tempo hanno comandato loro a Firenze
e la brava gente che lavorava e faceva i soldi
però si toglieva il cappello davanti al magnate di passaggio.
Poi c'è venuto un momento,
all'epoca di cui parliamo sono quasi cent'anni ormai
che funziona così,
è venuto un momento in cui la brava gente che lavora e fa i soldi
ha detto basta, i nobili sono gente troppo pericolosa,
troppo violenta, perché capite, non l'ho detto con abbastanza chiarezza,
i nobili sono gli specialisti del combattimento.
Tutti a Firenze sono armati e sanno andare in guerra se c'è bisogno,
ma i nobili sono i professionisti,
fanno quello fin da bambini, a cavallo, in armatura,
giocano alla guerra.
E il gioco della guerra i nobili lo portano anche nella politica.
È un comune dove si fa politica,
in mille modi si elegge, si vota, si sorteggia,
si riuniscono tanti consigli, commissioni,
ma i nobili sono quelli che quando il governo non gli piace
sono capaci di scendere in piazza armati in tanti,
fan venire i loro contadini da fuori,
occupano la piazza
e costringono il governo a fare quello che vogliono loro,
oppure si litigano fra loro e si ammazzano in piazza.
Bene, a un certo momento la brava gente che lavora a Firenze
ha detto sai che c'è? Basta.
I nobili non devono più fare politica in questa città.
Questa città la governiamo noi, il popolo.
E hanno fatto gli ordinamenti di giustizia
che dicono che i nobili,
benché siano cittadini come gli altri,
autorevoli, rispettati, ricchi, importanti,
vivono qui in mezzo a noi,
ma i nobili d'ora in poi, poltrone nel governo,
non possono averle.
Si fanno gli elenchi,
si fanno gli elenchi delle famiglie,
si va a vedere voi avete dei cavalieri in famiglia?
Li segniamo nell'elenco.
Quelli che hanno dei cavalieri in famiglia
sono nemici del popolo,
noi non ci fidiamo di loro.
E da quasi un secolo
i nobili non possono più essere sorteggiati
per fare i priori,
per entrare nei principali consigli.
Allora, ma se è così,
se il popolo governa da tanto tempo,
ma perché il gonfaloniere Salvestro De Medici
quel giorno di giugno
va a Palazzo Vecchio
a proporre di rafforzare
gli ordinamenti di giustizia?
Cioè, davvero i nobili fanno ancora così paura?
Allora, qual è il punto?
Il punto è che
non ci sarebbe più motivo
a dire la verità.
Ma le vecchie parole d'ordine
continuano a infiammare la gente.
I fiorentini hanno respirato
col latte materno
da generazioni
l'idea che i magnati,
i grandi, i cavalieri
sono nemici del popolo
e sono pericolosi.
Non è più vero.
Ma le vecchie parole d'ordine
ideologiche continuano a funzionare.
Quanti di voi si ricordano
che 25 anni fa
qua in Italia
qualcuno ha vinto le elezioni
agitando la paura dei comunisti?
Ecco.
Nel 1994
i comunisti
non avrebbero dovuto
più far paura a nessuno.
Invece
la gente
automaticamente
per tanto tempo
continua ad avere
le vecchie paure.
Allora,
Salvestro De Medici
è un politicante,
è un uomo
che sa
che agitare
le vecchie parole d'ordine
può sempre funzionare.
Serve quando un politico
ha bisogno
di ottenere visibilità,
serve per creare consenso,
per crearsi un ruolo.
Io,
il difensore del popolo.
Oppure serve
per creare tensioni.
Se uno ha interesse
a pescare nel torbido
anche lì
va sempre bene
dire c'è pericolo,
dobbiamo fare nuove leggi,
inasprire le leggi,
la sicurezza.
Ecco,
d'accordo?
Sto facendo dell'anacronismo
ma fino a un certo punto
perché funziona così.
E allora,
Salvestro De Medici
è andato dai priori
con questa proposta
e i priori
gli dicono picche
perché i priori
sono di quel popolo grasso
che ormai
tutta quella paura
dei magnati
non ce l'ha più.
Il popolo grasso
ha fatto i soldi,
sono più ricchi
dei magnati,
sono imparentati
con loro,
si sono fatti
anche loro i palazzi,
il popolo grasso
vorrebbe continuare
a guadagnare tranquillo
senza più creare
tensioni inutili
con questi nobili
che in fondo
sono ecco,
non fanno ecco.
Però,
però Salvestro De Medici
i suoi calcoli
li ha fatti.
Quando i priori
gli dicono
no,
non c'è nessun bisogno,
Salvestro De Medici
esce dalla sala,
dice un cronista
nessuno sapeva
dove fosse andato.
Il punto è che lui
ha già fatto i suoi calcoli
in un'altra sala
di Palazzo Vecchio
ha fatto riunire
il consiglio del popolo
e il consiglio del popolo
non sono otto priori,
sono molte centinaia
di membri
e questo vuol dire
che fra questa gente
ci sono i ricchi,
i grandi banchieri,
gli industriali,
ma ci sono anche
i piccoli imprenditori,
gli artigiani,
i bottegai,
la gente che tira la carretta
e Salvestro De Medici
va da questa gente
a dire
a dire che i priori
non gli permettono
di ripulire la città
dalla prepotenza
dei nobili
e i priori
sono dei venduti,
sono dei nemici
del popolo anche loro
e lui
Salvestro De Medici
è quello che voleva
difenderlo il popolo
dalla prepotenza
dei ricchi
ma
non glielo lasciano fare,
perciò
vi stupirete
di come cambia poco
la politica
lui dice
che si dimette
mi dimetto
da gonfaloniere
testuale eh
pertanto
io me ne voglio andare
a casa mia
e fate un altro
gonfaloniere
in luogo mio
e fatevi con Dio
naturalmente
questa sceneggiata
ha successo
il popolo
che è maggioranza
nel consiglio
il popolo minuto
i piccoli
gli artigiani
comincia a rumoreggiare
Salvestro è il nostro uomo
e i priori venduti
non gli vogliono
lasciar fare queste cose
e anche nel consiglio
qua ce li abbiamo
qua i venduti
i ricchi
i popolani grassi
tutti i traditori
e i popolani grassi
presenti
cominciano a vedere
che la grande maggioranza
li guarda male
e gli viene sotto
a muso duro
un cronista
racconta questa scena
c'è lì
Carlo Strozzi
gli Strozzi
sapete palazzo Strozzi
quindi potete immaginare
come si collocano
popolo
per carità
non sono un'antica
famiglia di cavalieri
popolo
però popolo grasso
molto grasso
e un calzolaio
si fa sotto
a Carlo Strozzi
e lo prende
per il bavero
in pieno consiglio
e gli dice
Carlo
le cose andranno
altrimenti
che tu non pensi
cioè le cose
non andranno
come credi tu
e le vostre
maggioranze
conviene
che al tutto
si spenghino
e cioè
è finita l'epoca
in cui voi ricchi
eravate
avevate la maggioranza
e governavate la città
è finita la cuccagna
ora capite
un calzolaio
che prende così
Carlo Strozzi
è come un calzolaio
che prende così
Marchionne
quello è il livello
e poi uno
dalla finestra
del palazzo vecchio
grida
viva il popolo
e quando uno grida
in pubblico
viva il popolo
è un segnale
che tutti capiscono
vuol dire
che il popolo
è in pericolo
e la gente
reagisce in automatico
cosa succede
quando si comincia
a gridare
viva il popolo
tutti rumoreggiano
tutti escono in strada
le botteghe
si chiudono
i negozianti
serrano tutto
la gente si arma
la gente va a casa
e si arma
perché tutti
hanno le armi
in casa
e poi corrono
tutti alla sede
della corporazione
loro
perché le corporazioni
sono organizzate
in modo militare
le corporazioni
governano la città
ma sanno
che devono difendere
il loro governo
fosse mai
che i nobili
un giorno
tentano il colpo
di stato
perciò le corporazioni
sono armate
e se tu sei
che ne so
un fabbro
quando senti
che gridano
e capisci
che c'è tumulto
vai a casa
prendi le armi
poi ti precipiti
alla sede
dell'arte
oppure se non trovi
più nessuno
vai a vedere
in piazza
dove sono i nostri
dove è il nostro
gonfalone
dei fabbri
con su
dipinte
le tenaglie
che sono
lo strumento
di lavoro
dei fabbri
e lì
tutti noi
fabbri
ci troviamo
tutti armati
a sentire
cosa comandano
i capi
della corporazione
e a questo punto
quindi la piazza
si riempie
delle corporazioni
in armi
che tumultuano
e gridano
ovviamente
gridano di più
i piccoli
gli industriali
della lana
avrebbero anche evitato
probabilmente
questa scena
ma ormai
le piccole corporazioni
le arti minori
come dicono loro
si sono spaventate
hanno occupato
la piazza
e rumoreggiano
perché i priori
non vogliono accettare
di inasprire
gli ordinamenti
di giustizia
tutti i traditori
i priori
chiusi dentro
il palazzo
tenete conto
che i priori
stanno in carica
due mesi
e in quei due mesi
stanno chiusi
dentro il palazzo
non è che vanno a casa
stanno lì dentro
anche per evitare
appunto
che ci sia
il colpo di stato
mentre loro sono fuori
per esempio
i priori
decidono
che va bene
aveva ragione
Salvestro de Medici
adottiamo
la sua proposta
e
e allora
si sparge la voce
si inaspiranno
gli ordinamenti
contro i magnati
ma i magnati
in città
contano ancora qualcosa
sono cent'anni
no
ottant'anni
che non possono avere
incarichi di governo
ma voi capite
sono tanti
ricchi
armati
continuano a contare
moltissimo
e poi
i magnati
qui vi rifilo
un'altra complicazione
ma è un mondo complesso
come vedete
per capire
la loro politica
avete mai sentito
parlare
di Guelfi
e Ghibellini
ecco
i Guelfi
e i Ghibellini
anche loro
sono lì
è una roba vecchia
vecchia
stravecchia
quelli che stanno
col papa
e quelli che stanno
con l'imperatore
Firenze
da tempo immemorabile
sta col papa
perché i banchieri
fiorentini
sono quelli
che finanziano
la chiesa
e quindi
c'è un legame
strettissimo
Firenze
può essere
solo Guelfa
a Firenze
i Ghibellini
sono stati messi
a tacere
da un sacco
di tempo
e Firenze
ufficialmente
è Guelfa
e c'è il partito
Guelfo
parte Guelfa
chi conosce Firenze
c'è il palazzo
di parte Guelfa
parte Guelfa
è il partito
che garantisce
l'ortodossia
della città
ed è il partito
che da un pezzo
ha capito
che per condizionare
il governo
di Firenze
c'è anche
questo modo
quando c'è
un uno
che sta facendo
un po' troppa
carriera politica
il consiglio
dei capi
della parte Guelfa
si riunisce
e dice
ci sono un po' troppi
Ghibellini
in giro
in questa città
e da tempo
che lo sappiamo
che ufficialmente
è proibito
è un Ghibellino
non può avere
nessun ufficio
un Ghibellino
vive in città
tollerato
ma paga più tasse
degli altri
e non può avere
nessun ufficio
ma chi è Ghibellino
e chi è Ghibellino
lo decide il partito
parte Guelfa
quindi periodicamente
pubblica delle liste
dicendo
il tale
127 nomi
tutti questi
ci risulta
che sono Ghibellini
ed ora in poi
non potranno più
avere nessun incarico
nessun ufficio
ora
qual è il paradosso
che questa specie
di mostro
impiantato dentro la città
questo partito
che garantisce
l'ortodossia
Guelfa
e che può colpire
chi vuole
accusandolo
di essere Ghibellino
e può rovinare
chi vuole
è tutto in mano
ai magnati
perché da sempre
il Guelfismo
è incarnato
soprattutto
dai nobili cavalieri
i magnati
che non possono avere
incarichi nel governo
controllano il partito
e in quel modo
condizionano il governo
quando si viene a sapere
che i priori
hanno adottato
i nuovi provvedimenti
restrittivi
contro i magnati
i magnati
reagiscono
come gli viene naturale
si radunano tutti
nel palazzo
di parte Guelfa
per decidere
cosa fare
e quello
è il loro errore
perché a quel punto
fino a un attimo
prima
erano le arti minori
che premevano
in piazza
i banchieri
gli industriali
ma se si viene a sapere
che i magnati
vogliono resistere
e allora
la vecchia paura
riprende tutti
e anche il popolo grasso
si compatta
col popolo minuto
e quindi
tutto questo
è capitato venerdì
sabato
le botteghe
restano chiuse
in tutta Firenze
sabato era un giorno
di lavoro normalissimo
in passato ovviamente
ecco
ma quel sabato
le botteghe restano chiuse
e la notte
le corporazioni
pattugliano in armi
la città
domenica
le arti
tutte insieme
grandi e piccoli
i ricchi
e quelli che tirano
che sgobbano a bottega
le arti
tutte insieme
decidono di mandare
una delegazione
dai priori
per chiedere una serie di cose
lunedì
i rappresentanti
delle arti
vanno dai priori
a palazzo
li ringraziano
per quello che hanno fatto
accettare la proposta
di Salvestro de' Medici
ma dicono
non basta
siamo stufi
di parte guelfa
che ci tiene
il gioco
sul collo
loro decidono
loro dicono
quello lì è ghibellino
rovinano
chi vogliono
siamo stufi
di questo gioco
e che per Dio
a questo
si provvedesse
e le arti
tutte
sono in piazza
armate
ognuna sotto
il suo gonfalone
e i priori
chiusi dentro
il palazzo
che devono
decidere
cosa fare
ma qui
succede
la cosa
del tutto
inaspettata
perché
finora
io vi ho parlato
di un popolo
cioè gli imprenditori
al governo
che decide
di dare una sterzata
contro i nobili
ma mentre
la piazza
è occupata
dalle arti
con tutti
i loro contingenti
armati
e i priori
dentro il palazzo
devono decidere
cosa fare
in piazza
cominciano
ad arrivare
anche gli altri
anche quelli
che non sono
iscritti
alle arti
gli operai
i lavoranti
i battilana
come dicono loro
tutta questa marea
di veri poveri
che lavorano
sotto padrone
nell'industria
della lana
e che non hanno
nessuna rappresentanza
politica
anche loro
cominciano
a entrare
in piazza
e ne arrivano
ne arrivano
sempre di più
e tutta questa gente
arrivata in piazza
a un certo punto
si accorge
di essere maggioranza
perché gli iscritti
alle arti
sono tantissimi
ma i lavoranti
sono ancora di più
e mentre le arti
sono inquadrate
sotto i loro gonfaloni
fermi lì
tutti sotto il sole
in attesa
che i capi decidano
la marea degli operai
comincia a sciamare
per tutta la città
e cominciano
a dare l'assalto
alle case
dei traditori
e chi sono i traditori?
Sono quei popolani
grassi
che sono diventati
troppo grassi
che la gente dice
che sono amici
dei magnati
in realtà
sono diventati
come i magnati
anche loro
non ci si può fidare
sono quelli
che sono stufi
si sa
è in città
che ci sono
dei nobili
no nobili
no ma
dei grossi proprietari
di industrie
di aziende
dei giudici
dei giuristi
che sono stufi
di questo governo largo
a cui partecipano
anche i ciabattini
e gli osti
che vorrebbero stringere
la gente lo sa
li conoscono per nome
Messerlapo
da Castiglionchi
o giudice
andiamo a bruciargli
la casa
e Messerlapo
da Castiglionchi
o giudice
fa appena in tempo
a scappare da Firenze
e gli bruciano la casa
a lui
e ad altri
i nemici del popolo
e quel giorno
vengono incendiate
le case degli strozzi
dei pazzi
degli albizi
dei soderini
tutte famiglie
si si
di popolo
in teoria
ma in realtà
traditori
dice la povera gente
e il furore
dice un testimone
di Laga
in città
dove si va
alle stinche
alla prigione
si rompe la prigione
e si liberano i carcerati
il che vuol dire
chiaramente
secondo noi
il governo è corrotto
e traditore
la giustizia
è traditrice
e i carcerati
sono carcerati
ingiustamente
tutti fuori
si dà l'assalto
ai conventi
perché?
perché a Firenze
queste cose
succedono spesso
e i tumulti
in piazza
e quando la situazione
è tesa
e ormai è tesa
da parecchi giorni
i ricchi
a Firenze
hanno un riflesso
condizionato
facciamo un bel
forziere
di roba preziosa
e lo portiamo
al convento
più vicino
dai francescani
a Santa Croce
dai domenicani
a Santa Maria Novella
perché se succede
il tumulto
i conventi
magari
verranno risparmiati
stavolta
non vengono risparmiati
anzi la folla
ci va apposta
dura solo un giorno
però
perché le arti
organizzate
sono ancora lì
e alla fine
il popolo
smette
di saccheggiare
anche perché
i priori
hanno fatto sapere
che guai
vietatissimo
e queste cose
saranno punite
la gente
si spaventa un po'
i priori
stringono
fanno arrestare
quattro
accusati
di aver incendiato
e saccheggiato
li fanno impiccare
in piazza
poi viene fuori
che sono quattro forestieri
che non c'entravano
niente
avete presente
Renzo Tramaglino
quando finisce
a Milano
nel tumulto
e arrestano solo lui
ecco è tipico
il montanaro
appena arrivato
arrestano questi quattro
li impiccano
in apparenza
è tutto finito
ma la botta
di vedere
gli operai
che saccheggiavano
e davano fuoco
alle case dei ricchi
non si digerisce
facilmente
in città
sono tutti spaventati
i ricchi
gli industriali
ma anche gli artigiani
sgombrano
le loro mercanzie
i cittadini
grossi
come dicono
i testimoni
assumono
guardie private
fanno venire
i loro contadini
dal podere
a fargli la guardia
alle case
sbarrano le porte
di notte
si fa la guardia
dappertutto
di giorno
le botteghe
stavano
a sportello
il che vuol dire
di solito
la bottega
è spalancata
sotto i portici
tutti entrano
in quei giorni
niente
il negoziante
è chiuso dentro
e apre lo sportellino
per vendere
non si fida
ad aprire
si va avanti
così per giorni
così per settimane
la città
è paralizzata
è giugno
c'è la festa
di San Giovanni Battista
la festa patronale
la più grande
festa della città
si corre il palio
quell'anno
niente
non si festeggia
San Giovanni Battista
non si corre il palio
il primo luglio
hanno sorteggiato
i nuovi priori
che entrano in carica
per luglio e agosto
normalmente
quando vengono
sorteggiati i priori
e quindi ogni due mesi
in tutta la città
si suonano
le campane
a festa
e poi i priori
dalla scalinata
o dal balcone
del palazzo
giurano davanti
al popolo
di osservare
le leggi
di Firenze
gli ordinamenti
questa volta
non si fa niente
non suonano
le campane
perché suonare
è sempre una cosa
pericolosa
in una città medievale
fosse mai che la gente
sente suonare le campane
e dice sta succedendo qualcosa
andiamo ad armarci
ecco
non suonano le campane
e i priori giurano
sì devono giurare
ma giurano dentro
il palazzo
a porte chiuse
non bisogna
dare nessun pretesto
perché scoppi di nuovo
l'incendio
e invece a questo punto
la situazione precipita
perché hanno tutti paura
i popolani grassi
al governo
hanno paura
che i saccheggi ricomincino
il popolo minuto
ha paura
dei traditori
al governo
quelli
ci sono anche
i guelfi
sinceri
che davvero
hanno paura
che tornino
i ghibellini
e quindi anche loro
tutti in allarme
e quelli
che hanno saccheggiato
quel giorno
hanno una gran paura
che adesso
che è tutto finito
la polizia
li venga a cercare
a casa
perché in quel caso
è la forca
garantita
quindi hanno tutti paura
e in questo clima
negli ultimi giorni
prima del 20 luglio
ai priori
cominciano ad arrivare
delle denunce
anonime
che dicono
guardate che gli operai
si stanno organizzando
hanno dei capi
hanno in mente
di fare qualcosa
guardate che gli operai
vogliono saccheggiare
Firenze
i priori
ricevono per qualche giorno
questi rapporti
queste denunce
poi le denunce
diventano precise
è per il 20 luglio
il 20 luglio
la massa
la plebe
dei sottoposti
insorgerà
e metterà
a sacco
Firenze
queste cose
arrivano
la sera del 19
i priori
sono sempre
lì chiusi
dentro Palazzo Vecchio
e devono decidere
cosa fare
nelle denunce
si fanno
alcuni nomi
decidono di farli arrestare
arrestano
quattro operai
e li interrogano
e dall'interrogatorio
di uno di questi arrestati
che si chiama
Simoncino
non ha neanche un cognome
è il popolo
il popolo non ha il cognome
Simoncino
figlio di Bartolomeo
e Simoncino
confessa
spontaneamente
sì è tutto vero
è tutto vero
tutti i sottoposti
dell'arte della lana
non vogliono più
essere sottoposti
non vogliamo più
dover ubbidire
ai padroni
all'arte della lana
che ha il suo funzionario
l'arte della lana
sovrintende
al lavoro degli operai
con arbitrio assoluto
c'è un funzionario
che si fa venire dall'estero
da fuori città
il quale
ha autorità totale
controlla il lavoro
degli operai
sei in ritardo
multa
questo lavoro
non mi piace
multa
dici che hai lavorato
otto ore
non è vero
te ne pago quattro
e gli operai
non hanno nessun diritto
di rispondere
basta
dice Simoncino
noi vogliamo
che questa cosa finisca
e vogliamo
che la smetta
questa storia
che non ci pagano
perché del lavoro
che vale dodici
ne danno otto
e anche dicono
che vogliono parte
nel reggimento
della città
questa è la frase
cruciale
dell'intera vicenda
Simoncino
interrogato dai priori
dice sì
vogliamo che sia abolito
l'ufficiale dell'arte
della lana
vogliamo essere pagati meglio
ma soprattutto
vogliamo anche noi
partecipare
al governo
della città
e cosa vuol dire
vuol dire che anche noi
vogliamo formare un'arte
perché i padroni
sono organizzati
e noi no
vogliamo che anche noi
operai
formiamo delle corporazioni
e che mettano nei sacchi
anche i nostri nomi
anche noi
vogliamo poter diventare
priori e gonfalonieri
di giustizia
quando si fa il sorteggio
i priori
devono decidere
cosa fare
è la notte
tra il 19
e il 20
la confessione
di Simoncino
dice sì
domattina il 20
gli operai
insorgono
i priori
hanno
come dire
un referente politico
le arti
e quindi
mandano ad avvertire
i capi delle arti
e a chiedere
cosa bisogna fare
i capi delle arti
dicono
siete sicuri
di queste confessioni
meglio essere
proprio sicuri
reinterrogateli
di nuovo
sotto tortura
li reinterrogano
e questi
ripetono tutto
con un'aggiunta
c'è un capo
Salvestro
li messerà la mano
dei medici
l'amico del popolo
tutto torna
sarà vero
non sarà vero
glielo hanno fatto dire
per forza
però Salvestro
si era ritagliato
quel ruolo
e quindi adesso
gli tocca
viene accusato
di essere lui
il capo
va bene
e allora
quella notte
arrestano
altri operai
li torturano
li interrogano
tutti confermano
l'insurrezione
per domani mattina
a questo punto
i priori
chiusi dentro
il palazzo
possono fare
un'unica cosa
sperare
che le arti
padroni
e padroncini
grandi e piccoli
tengano duro
e siano disposti
a sostenere
il governo
contro la rivolta
perciò
l'ordine
è domattina
all'alba
tutte le arti
in piazza
tutti armati
sotto i loro gonfaloni
a difendere
palazzo vecchio
perché dai quartieri
bassi
arriverà la feccia
a dare l'assalto
a palazzo vecchio
la scommessa
è che le arti
tengano
e cioè
che anche il calzolaio
e l'oste
decidano di stare
con l'industriale
e col banchiere
contro gli operai
sarà così
lo vedremo
domani mattina
in realtà
non c'è da aspettare
la mattina
perché tutti questi interrogatori
sono stati condotti
in gran segreto
nelle cantine
di palazzo vecchio
dentro non c'è nessuno
che possa sapere
cosa sta succedendo
e riferirlo fuori
no invece c'è uno
c'è l'orologiaio
che sta aggiustando
l'orologio
di palazzo vecchio
perché siamo nel medioevo
ma c'è l'orologio
naturalmente
c'è l'orologio pubblico
questa è una grande
città industriale
e il tempo è scandito
dall'orologio
del comune
che batte le ore
e c'è l'orologiaio
in palazzo
è l'unico estraneo
c'è l'orologiaio
che sta aggiustando
l'orologio
e sente gridare
quelli che vengono
torturati
l'orologiaio
sente tutto
e poi esce
e l'orologiaio
è uno del popolo
è un piccolo artigiano
anche lui
e lui decide
che non sta
con i priori
traditori
amici dei ricchi
lui sta col popolo
perciò l'orologiaio
esce
va a casa
si arma
non è ancora
l'alba
e poi esce
in strada
l'orologiaio
gridando
allarme
i priori
fanno carne
vuol dire
ammazzano la gente
capite
sei un uomo
e lo trasformi
in carne
i priori
fanno carne
armatevi
cattiva gente
che non vuol dire
come vorrebbe dire
per noi
malvagia
vuol dire
poveretti
armatevi
poveri voi
se non
che sarete
tutti morti
e a questo punto
suonano le campane
a martello
in tutta la città
all'alba
i priori
sono dentro
il palazzo
hanno fatto venire
un centinaio
di soldati
i soldati
sono schierati
in piazza
in armatura
fermi lì
sono mercenari
i priori
aspettano
che arrivino
le arti
organizzate
con i loro gonfaloni
non arriva
nessuno
e invece
arriva il popolo
arrivano
gli operai
gli insorti
questa gente
dicono i testimoni
che si cominciarono
a chiamare
i cionpi
perché la parola cionpi
voi leggerete
sui dizionari
che vuol dire
gli operai
dell'arte
della lana
ma
non ci metterei
la mano sul fuoco
perché voglio studiarlo
ancora un po'
ma la mia impressione
ora come ora
è che non era
una parola
di uso comune
dilaga
in quel momento
perché come ho già detto ieri
quando nel medioevo
c'è una rivolta
tutti sentono il bisogno
di trovare un nome
per indicare
quelli che fanno parte
della rivolta
e perciò questa parola
di colpo
diventa di uso universale
chi sono i cionpi
sono gli operai
insorti
quello sono i cionpi
e i cionpi
occupano la piazza
gridando naturalmente
cosa
viva il popolo
perché capite
l'ambiguità
di questa parola
popolo
che a seconda
di come la rigiri
può voler dire
il banchiere
o può voler dire
i poveretti
e chi mai
non accetterebbe
di gridare
viva il popolo
nessuno se lo può permettere
i cionpi
gridano viva il popolo
i soldati
e i soldati
non si muovevano
anzi
stavano a vedere
loro sono mercenari
perché dovrebbero
rischiare la pelle
quando le arti
che dovevano
sostenere
il loro governo
non si sono fatte
vedere
i priori
sono chiusi dentro
da sotto
urlano
liberate
gli arrestati
dopo un po'
da sotto
cominciano a tirare
con le balestre
contro le finestre
del palazzo
a questo punto
i priori
cedono
e liberano
gli arrestati
come che
tra priori
fossin di quelli
che dicessino
rendansi
in due pezzi
per chi non capisse
il Toscano
e il Trecento
tra i priori
c'era chi diceva
sì sì
li restituiamo
gli arrestati
in due pezzi
prima gli tagliamo
la testa
e poi li restituiamo
ma non hanno il coraggio
di farlo
li liberano
la gente
in piazza
urla
grida
e il grido
adesso è
andiamo a
saccheggiare
i palazzi
che mancano
i traditori
sono tanti
cominciano a dare
l'assalto
ai palazzi degli
industriali
dei lanaioli
bruciare
saccheggiare
fuoco
e carne
i capi
dicono
no
momento
noi
non siamo
questo
vietato
saccheggiare
ma bruciare
sì
perché quelli
sono i nemici
del popolo
e meritano
che le loro case
vengano bruciate
i priori
quella notte
fanno venire
pane
vino
aceto
carne salata
formaggio
e sale
e grandi
carichi di pietre
per difendersi
dalle finestre
nel caso
che il popolo
rimanga fuori
il popolo
rimane fuori
il 21 mattina
diluvia
bomba d'acqua
diremmo noi oggi
uno di quei
diluvi estivi
terrificanti
i priori
dentro il palazzo
sperano che la gente
torni a casa
la gente
non torna
a casa
anzi
i cionpi
insorti
hanno fatto dire
alle arti
di venire in piazza
anche loro
ad aiutarli
e le arti
visto che
la plebe
è padrona
della città
non osano
non venire
poi i cronisti
dicono
e chi venne
e chi no
però intanto
le arti
vengono
manca una
potete immaginare
quale
l'arte della lana
non si fa vedere
ma tutte le altre
corporazioni
vengono
a dare appoggio
agli operai
insorti
e gli operai
presentano
le loro richieste
e la principale
è che anche loro
vogliono come dicevo
organizzarsi in arti
devono essere riconosciute
tre nuove arti
una la più grande
tutti i sottoposti
della lana
un'altra
i sarti
che anche loro
sono dei piccoli
poveri
e un'altra
i tintori
tre arti nuove
e ogni arte nuova
deve avere
i suoi priori
sorteggiati
ogni volta
e anche il gonfaloniere
deve poter essere
uno dei nostri
i priori
sono chiusi nel palazzo
e devono decidere
gli diciamo di sì
o gli diciamo di no
da sotto
gridano
fa un caldo
spaventoso
i priori
sono chiusi
lì dentro
la folla fuori
tumultua
e le grida
andavano al cielo
che non si udiva
nulla
nella sala
però qualcosa
in realtà udivano
a un certo punto
sentono che in piazza
qualcuno comincia a gridare
andiamo a bruciare
le case dei priori
a questo punto
i priori votano
le richieste del popolo
e diventa legge
di Firenze
che si creano
queste nuove
corporazioni
dopodiché
uno dei priori
che non ne può più
esce da una porticina
e scappa a casa
ma non dovevi farlo
perché i priori
per obbligo costituzionale
in quei due mesi
stanno nel palazzo
il priore che è uscito
è come se si fosse dimesso
lo vedono
e quindi il popolo
comincia a dire
fuori i priori
fuori
li vogliamo nuovi
via i vecchi
e il popolo
sciama nel palazzo
mentre i priori
scappano a casa
il popolo
prende il palazzo
e trovano la prova
che i priori
erano traditori
da qualche parte
in palazzo vecchio
trovano i capestri
i quali avvien
incomperati
per impiccare
i poveri
poi chi lo sa
se quei capestri
c'erano da sempre
ma invece la voce
corre subito
vedi
volevano impiccarci
hanno perfino
comprato i capestri
i giovani
sono sempre i giovani
all'avanguardia
sciamano nel palazzo
salgono sulla torre
suonano le campane
a festa
in segno di vittoria
viene fatto a pezzi
il bargello
il capo effettivo
della polizia
il bargello
sernuto
che
dice un cronista
era quello
che aveva promesso
al popolo grasso
che reggeva prima
di impiccare
i poveri
il bargello
è un funzionario
che come si usa
è fatto venire da fuori
come l'ufficiale
dell'arte della lana
perché quelli
che devono fare
i lavori sporchi
li facciamo venire
da fuori
il bargello
sernuto
poteva anche
cavarsela
è un forestiero
sta all'albergo
era chiuso
nel suo albergo
nessuno
sapeva dove fosse
e nessuno
pensava a lui
a sernuto
viene la bella idea
di farsi la barba
manda a chiamare
un barbiere
il barbiere
manda un garzone
il garzone
fa la barba
a sernuto
non l'ha riconosciuto
non sa chi sia
quando il garzone
ha finito
di fargli la barba
il servo
di sernuto
lo deve pagare
e dice al padrone
sernuto
che gli do
il garzone
sente
sernuto
fa due più due
lo riconosce
va fuori
e dice
sernuto
è lì
è chiuso
in quella
sernuto
il bargello
quello che avevano
fatto venire
per ammazzarci tutti
certo
lui
il popolo
va a prenderlo
lo trascinano fuori
vogliono impiccarlo
ma non fanno in tempo
perché lo odiano
talmente tanto
che lo ammazzano
e poi lo impiccano
per i piedi
già morto
e poi lo fanno
a pezzettini
commenta un cronista
per una volta
abbiamo anche
dei cronisti
favorevoli
all'insurrezione
qui
abbiamo anche
della gente
che dice
l'insurrezione
è stata sacrosanta
giustissima
meno male
peccato che poi
è finita male
ma era sacrosanta
e uno di questi cronisti
commenta
certo
hanno fatto la pelle
a sernuto
era fatto venire
per fare carne
d'uomini
e poi
e poi noi
il popolo
abbiamo preso
il potere
e noi siamo
legittimo
in questa città
quindi adesso
nomineremo
i nuovi priori
ma innanzitutto
ci vuole un gonfaloniere
di giustizia
non si può
senza un gonfaloniere
di giustizia
non si può
far niente
lui è il potere
esecutivo
chi lo fa
sono andati
a prendere
il gonfalone
della giustizia
per far vedere
che loro
sono appunto
i legittimi
detentori
della sovranità
hanno il gonfalone
di giustizia
chi lo porta
e ce l'ha in mano
un fattorino
di un industriale
della lana
si chiama
Michele Di Lando
è venuto lì
in calzoncini corti
dicono
senza calze
è lui
fa un caldo da morire
e questo qui
si trova a avere in mano
il gonfalone
fallo tu
il gonfaloniere
di giustizia
e Michele Di Lando
figlio di una venditrice
del mercato
e fattorino
di un industriale
si trova
di colpo
gonfaloniere
di giustizia
di Firenze
unica autorità
esistente
perché i priori
sono tutti a casa
per un giorno e mezzo
Michele Di Lando
governa Firenze
ci sono rimaste
le ordine
lo so che è tardi
ma mi avvio a finire
ci sono rimaste
delle lettere
delle ordinanze
firmate da lui
Michele Di Lando
gonfaloniere
di giustizia
i cronisti ostili
potete immaginare
per un giorno e mezzo
Firenze
è stata governata
da questo
pezzente
in calzoncini corti
nemmeno le bracche
possedeva
ecco
dopodiché
create le nuove arti
bisogna procedere
al sorteggio
dei nuovi priori
e quindi
quindi bruciamo
tutti i vecchi sacchi
con i vecchi nomi
e facciamo i nuovi sacchi
con i nomi nuovi
anche i nostri
adesso
ce li mettiamo
è una procedura
lunghissima
i cronisti ostili
dicono
non potete immaginare
come l'hanno fatta
questa cosa
tutti i pezzenti
lì
a scrivere
questi nomi
immigrati
gente che non si sapeva
chi erano
e questi qua
volevano governare
Firenze
e hanno fatto
le nuove borse
e poi sorteggiano
e uno dei cronisti
non sappiamo
come si chiama
ma è uno che c'era
partecipato a queste cose
e lui era contentissimo
dice ah
questa operazione
di sorteggio
loro lo chiamavano
lo scrutinio
che però in fiorentino
dell'epoca suonava
lo squittino
e lo squittino
ecco
ci mettono settimane
a fare i sacchi
con tutti i nomi
poi estrarre i nuovi priori
e lo squittinatore
è il nome di questo
diarista anonimo
che partecipa
e lo dice
fu fatto
il buono squittino
che contentò
molta gente
i quali
non avevano mai
avuto parte
d'ufficio
e sempre
erano stati
alle spese
perché noi
i poveri
noi le tasse
le paghiamo
ma un ufficio
non l'avevamo mai visto
una carica
una poltrona
ecco
e col sistema
di prima
dice
non ebbono mai
nieno guadagno
se non i ricchi
ovviamente voi capite
che il sottinteso
è
quando hai
una poltrona
tutto sommato
e non è solo
l'onore
ecco
perché i ricchi
le volevano tutte loro
finora le poltrone
adesso ce l'abbiamo
anche noi
finalmente
dopo aver pagato tanto
è ora di guadagnare
un po'
ordine
di far festa
aprire le botteghe
tedeum
campane a gloria
confetti e vino
per tutti
in piazza
la città festeggia
ma non tutti
festeggiano
i lanaioli
non festeggiano
i banchieri
i bottegai
sono lì
che si chiedono
abbiamo fatto bene
ad aiutare
questi poveracci
o era meglio
lasciar perdere
la città
è in sospeso
le botteghe
non aprono
molti cittadini
sgombrano
le famiglie
in campagna
la gente
mormora
i priori
proibiscono
di mandare
la famiglia
in campagna
molta gente
comincia a chiedersi
che razza di governo
abbiamo
vedete come è facile
scivolare
dall'entusiasmo
del trionfo
ai provvedimenti
dittatoriali
che ti fanno
perdere il consenso
e come in tutte
le rivoluzioni
nasce la milizia
rivoluzionaria
nascono le guardie rosse
i priori
ordino di arruolare
mille balestrieri
fra il popolo minuto
fra i poveri
stipendiati
dal comune
e arruolano
questi balestrieri
i quali
ogni giorno
si esercitano
in città
in pubblico
dicendo parole
villane
contro agli altri
cittadini
perché è chiaro
ogni milizia
rivoluzionaria
vede i nemici
del popolo
dappertutto
e allora
in questa situazione
il problema
è che il ritorno
alla normalità
è impossibile
anche perché i cionpi
si sono abituati
a stare in piazza
a stare sotto il palazzo
e a gridare
pretendono
e i malcontenti
i ricchi malcontenti
sobillano
il popolo minuto
e vi imboccano
col cucchiaio vuoto
vi imboccano
tante promesse
tante parole
avete visto qualcosa
niente
anche questi nuovi priori
è vero
ci sono anche i nostri
dentro
tre dei nuovi priori
sono operai adesso
ma anche loro
anche loro
traditori
una volta che sei lì
a palazzo
e noi siamo sotto
in piazza
non ci fidiamo
cacciamoli via tutti
creano una nuova
commissione rivoluzionaria
gli otto
d'ora in poi
saranno gli otto
che governano Firenze
e i priori
beh
quando a fine agosto
scadono
li facciamo nuovi
col sorteggio
dalle borse
ma sotto
il controllo
degli otto
e gli otto
capi della rivoluzione
diciamo così
sono lì in palazzo
e ogni volta
che viene fuori
un nome
dalle borse
uno va alla finestra
e grida al popolo
è venuto fuori
il tal dei tali
lo volete
no
che non lo vogliamo
e allora niente
quello si butta via
e se ne sorteggia
un altro
finché non vengono fuori
dei nomi
che piacciono
alla piazza
e il problema
è che a questo punto
i cionpi
perdono la maggioranza
del consenso
in città
perché loro
sono tanti
ma sono tanti
anche gli artigiani
i bottegai
i piccoli
sono tanti anche i ricchi
e i piccoli
sono tantissimi
tutti quelli
che hanno bottega
e interessi
e che si sono lasciati
trascinare
in quei giorni
a dire dai
facciamo questa rivoluzione
hanno ragione i poveri
ma dopo qualche giorno
ci stanno tutti
ripensando
e i priori
stessi
benché alcuni
di loro
siano operai
anche loro
appena nominati
appena sorteggiati
però di questa cosa
che loro priori
governano con la piazza sotto
piena di folla
che gli urla dietro
neanche loro
si stanno più
e a questo punto
è tutto molto veloce
perché i capi
delle arti
molto rapidamente
fanno girare
il passaparola
siamo d'accordo
che così non va bene
sì siamo d'accordo
siamo d'accordo
che questo governo
della feccia
non può continuare
sì siamo d'accordo
i priori cosa dicono
i priori non possono dirlo
ma stanno con noi
è ora di farla finita
e allora come si fa
a farla finita
eh
si fa finita
perché andiamo in piazza
in tanti
tutti armati
e tutti decisi
a farla finita
in questo clima
i cionpi
a loro volta
non sono contenti
di niente
hanno nuove richieste
portano ai priori
le nuove richieste
vanno due degli otto
due dei capi
della giunta rivoluzionaria
vanno a palazzo
vanno dai priori
questo è l'elenco
delle nuove richieste
il gonfaloniere di giustizia
gli va incontro
tira fuori la spada
li colpisce
li butta giù tutti e due
li fa arrestare
eppure questo era il governo
del popolo
eh
sorteggiato
con la gente sotto
che diceva
sì quello lo vogliamo
ma in pochi giorni
sono diventati il governo
e non vogliono più
che la piazza comandi
a questo punto
il popolo
la feccia
come dicono loro
i cionpi sono sotto
e non sanno
cosa sta succedendo
ma cominciano ad arrivare
gli artigiani
e i mercanti
organizzati
in armi
con i loro gonfaloni
i cionpi non sanno
anche l'altro giorno
erano in piazza
a sostenerci
quindi
che si fa
e i cionpi
sono lì
hanno anche loro
un loro gonfalone
della loro nuova insegna
con un angelo
dipinto sopra
e vedono arrivare
la folla
delle arti organizzate
e non sanno
cosa sta succedendo
invece quelli delle arti
sanno cosa sta succedendo
perché i capi
hanno passato parola
a tutti
andiamo in piazza
per farla finita
con la rivoluzione
e in una parte
della piazza
ci sono i cionpi
e dall'altra parte
arrivano gli artigiani
e i mercanti
armati
con i loro gonfaloni
e sono sempre di più
e i cionpi
cominciano a preoccuparsi
qualcuno dice
ma non è che siamo traditi
non è che i priori
ci hanno traditi
dal palazzo
esce il gonfaloniere
di giustizia
e dice no
quale tradimento
quei due degli otto
che ci avete mandato
erano traditori
li abbiamo arrestati
volevano la dittatura
volevano dare la città
in mano a un signore
sono tutte parole d'ordine
che in un comune italiano
fanno subito scattare le cose
come volevano un signore
e noi non lo vogliamo
allora erano davvero traditori
quei due
e qualcuno in piazza
comincia a dire
buttate giù
i priori operai
non li vogliamo più
traditori tutti
e altri dicono no
però se sono traditori
bisogna processarli
giudicare
e i ricchi invece gridano
buttateli giù dalle finestre
e in piazza
il popolo organizzato
le arti
affluisce
sempre di più
mentre i cionpi
non sanno bene
cosa sta succedendo
molta gente
pioveva da ogni parte
alla piazza
specialmente i grassi
e gli artefici
gli artigiani
minuti e grandi
perché sapevano
il fatto
del trattato
che doveva essere
cioè sapevano
che c'era l'accordo
a un certo punto
un gruppo di cionpi
vede un gruppo
di artigiani
armati
un po' troppo arroganti
vanno a dirgli
cosa fate qua in piazza
sgombrate
e non si volia impartire
quelli non volevano
andarsene
perché sapevano
perché vi stavano
in altre parole
tutti i resoconti
battono sul fatto
che la controrivoluzione
è perfettamente
organizzata
le corporazioni
sono un meccanismo
di trasmissione
straordinario
in un attimo
hai in piazza
migliaia di persone
armate
che hanno ricevuto
la parola d'ordine
sanno cosa stiamo
andando a fare
stanno lì
quasi tutto il giorno
a fronteggiarsi
poi tre ore prima
del tramonto
chiedono ai cionpi
di cedere il loro gonfalone
i cionpi
non lo cedono
il gonfalone
se lo sono appena conquistato
il simbolo del fatto
che loro sono
una corporazione
ufficiale
riconosciuta
non lo cedete
e a questo punto
gli altri attaccano
davanti a tutti
i macellai
centinaia
di giovanotti
nerboruti
armati
con gli attrezzi
del mestiere
la mannaia
il coltellaccio
i macellai
vanno avanti
gli osti
vengono dietro
e poi via via
i bottai
i muratori
tutte le corporazioni
artigiane
danno addosso
ai cionpi
e i cionpi
presi completamente
di sorpresa
si sbandano
scappano
dal palazzo
i priori
gli fanno tirare
addosso
con le balestre
e vedendo
che anche dal palazzo
i loro priori
tradiscono
il popolo
perde completamente
la testa
scappano tutti
a casa
molti morti
in piazza
poi durante la notte
le milizie
delle arti
setacciano
i quartieri
popolari
non uccidono
nessuno
ma bastonano
sequestrano
le armi
violentano donne
riprendono
il possesso
della città
e l'indomani
in piazza
ci sono solo
le arti
organizzate
e allora si comincia
per prima cosa
dov'è il gonfalone
dei cionpi
l'abbiamo preso
eccolo
stracciato
e calpestato
in pubblico
e poi
i tre priori
cionpi
anche se hanno
sostenuto
la contro rivoluzione
però non li vogliamo più
facciate
con te
sti gaglioffi
giuso
buttateli giù
questi gaglioffi
i tre priori
operai
dicono
noi andremo a casa
abbiamo capito
che non è da noi
fare i priori
gente della nostra condizione
no no
tutto dimenticato
lasciateci solo tornare a casa
li fanno scortare
dalla polizia
a casa
fine dei priori
cionpi
in piazza
c'è un artigiano
che si lascia scappare
che non è giusto
perché i lavoranti
della lana avevano ragione
di che
fu morto
in sulla piazza
lo ammazzano
sul posto
la partecipazione
del popolo
non organizzato
agli uffici
è abolita
l'arte dei cionpi
le altre due arti
nuove
i tintori
e i sarti
le lasciano
perfino loro
hanno tradito
con l'idea
noi ci lasciate qualcosa
hanno abbandonato
gli operai
e quindi
si rifà il governo
distribuendo i posti
tra le arti minori
e le arti maggiori
si proibisce
che d'ora in poi
qualunque
sottoposto
dell'arte
della lana
possa avere
un qualunque
ufficio
in comune
e poi
si fa festa
si scrive
alle città
alleate
che la terra
era tornata
alla signoria
di mercatanti
e buoni uomini
cioè di gente
per bene
girano le canzoni
che prendono in giro
questi poveracci
che non si sa
chi era loro padre
gente che nacque ieri
e che credevano
di poter comandare
loro in città
viene deciso
che d'ora in poi
il giorno
di San Giuliano
e quel giorno
in cui i cionpi
sono stati sbaragliati
sarà festa nazionale
del comune di Firenze
il giorno
che furono
i sconfitti
i cionpi di Firenze
e per mesi
bisogna stare
molto attenti
a quello che si dice
molti mesi dopo
c'è un artigiano
che si fa sentire
a dire
che questo governo
che abbiamo adesso
non è buono
e che non durerà
viene preso
arrestato
e gli tagliano
la lingua
e la mano destra
per esempio
agli altri
non bisogna
andare in giro
a dire certe cose
e poi
e poi naturalmente
cosa succede
che poi
congiure
impiccagioni
i cionpi
vorrebbero ancora
insorgere
non ci riescono
il governo
stringe naturalmente
perché stringe
perché adesso
che abbiamo vinto
le due arti nuove
dei sarti
e dei tintori
che all'ultimo momento
le abbiamo salvate
perché sono passate
dalla parte dei ricchi
ma non durano mica
un paio d'anni dopo
viene deciso
di abolire anche quelle
e non c'è più nessuno
che abbia la forza
di resistere
e le arti minori
gli ostiti
i muratori
i macellai
che hanno avuto
grosse promesse
avrete
la maggioranza
dei priori
cinque su nove
poi no
scusate troppi
quattro su nove
poi nuova riforma
tre su nove
due su nove
e il gonfaloniere
di giustizia
deve essere
delle arti maggiori
e tutte queste cose
passano
perché hanno tutti paura
e nessuno
è più in grado
di reagire
e come dire
ieri ho finito
il racconto
della Jacquerie
in Francia
sottolineando
che molti secoli
dopo
certo
in una Francia
cambiata
da tanti punti di vista
ma tutto sommato
c'erano sempre
i re
i nobili
e il popolo di Parigi
sempre pronto
a insorgere
e i contadini
ecco
era un mondo diverso
ma non così diverso
qualche secolo dopo
la fine del medioevo
in Francia
una rivoluzione
riporterà
in campo
alcuni dei motivi
per cui si era combattuto
nella grande rivolta
della Jacquerie
sarebbe bello
poter finire
anche stasera
dicendo
beh
la rivolta
dei cionpi
è stata solo
una rivolta
non una rivoluzione
perché è stata sedata
con violenza
certo
ma i semi
li ha lasciati
e nella storia
d'Italia
poi come tutti sappiamo
c'è stata
la grande rivoluzione
libertaria
del
ecco
mettete la data
che volete
perché tanto
non c'è stata
in Italia
è tutto finito lì
quella volta
grazie
grazie a tutti
Grazie.